noël à problèmes à l approche et les
chaînes info en parle de plus en plus
bfm s'est penchée jeudi sur le phénomène
marie ackah huawei pendant les fêtes
notamment avec son tube intemporel we
all i want for christmas is you c'est à
dire tout ce que je veux pour noël c'est
toi et ben génère un pognon incroyable
gerber ces valeurs si incroyable
regarder l'argent et ça génère mais
c'est beau franchement si une meuf vous
dit tout ce que je peux pour noël c'est
toi tino rossi je crois quoi deuxième
d'atenor aussi deux minutes on parle on
parle d'amour là une femme qui vous a
dit tout ce que je veux c'est juste tout
pour noël c'est mois après c'est moi
mais chez moi des louboutin quand même
ses parts et regarde mariah carey est
connu pour son tempérament de dhiba ses
robes à paillettes mais aussi pour son
tube pratiquement devenu l'hymne
officiel de noël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson sortie en 1994 est la plus
écoutée chaque année pendant la période
des fêtes est extrait de son album merry
christmas écoulé à plus de cinq millions
d'exemplaires
au total la chanson cumul 462 millions
de vues sur youtube et plus de 200
millions des coudes sur spotify un
phénomène qui s'amplifie encore en
l'espace de seulement deux ans la
chanson a doublé son nombre de vues sur
internet et pour faire perdurer cette
poule aux oeufs d'or la chanteuse sont
régulièrement des nouvelles versions
comme ce remix en 2011 aux côtés de
justin bieber
[Musique]
chaque année un all i want for christmas
tour une manière habile de profiter au
maximum du buzz autour de son titre et
de récolter all she want for christmas
c'est à dire pas mal d'argent
[Applaudissements]
elle est très jolie et très diverses la
rencontrer ah ouais je suis sûr que tu
aimerais 10 et j'étais dans une salle et
elle m'a vu comme ça elle a fait comme
ça j'aurais dit oui c'est moi et chez
nous comme ça you do not by fred voiture
va chanter l'amour c'est vrai mariah
carey gtl et j'étais son délire ouais
elle adore les vendeurs de kebabs et son
équipe
non non on s'en fout merci c'est drôle
ça va intéresser les filles mais que ce
soit en équipe comme elle veut pas
admettre qu'elle a grossi son équipe
enlève toutes les étiquettes de satin et
remplace pas d y est marqué 34 cas c'est
très intelligent